there he is 8:36 local tiger pulls up in
the all-black straight focus trunk
raises time to get the tools a little
bit more though than an hour later his
main competitor completely different
disposition guys phil mickelson joyous
ready to rock you've been waiting for it
it has arrived Capital One's oh yeah
so tire you and Phil nine million how
you see a plane out I seen anyway
English I don't know how it's going to
play out but I already know what the end
results going to be it's going to be a
very intense match we're gonna be each
other's brains and I think it's a great
spot to do it out there at shadow Creek
in Vegas Las Vegas Sin City the gambling
capital of the world
it's classic of tiger and Phil to
elevate the game again from what they've
done in the past for tiger
it's definitely gonna be one for the
ages Tiger his dedication to be the
greatest it was the best call from the
planet for a long time he's dominated
the sport like we've never seen Tigers
highlight-reel he's destroyed fields had
that real killer instinct and cheap
Italian meant business he took care of
business number 80 till the thrill good
or bad
whatever the result he went for it what
a shot this is
[Applause]
it's amazing to look at the crew that
phil has had the word of god he'll go
down top-10 player to ever live he's a
legend the two most popular players in
the game today put on a show to be going
at it against each other head-to-head
like this to play for something this
huge brings out a certain pressure and
makes for a great opportunity I think
this is something that they're all
remember of course it's going to be the
easiest nine million I've ever made
all I've got to do is be tiger in one
round why do I think I win because I
will win not complicated I'm not not
complicated enough then of course Shadow
Creek the exclusive golf oasis in Las
Vegas Nevada
you know the icons Tiger Phil legends
rooted in rivalry and that prize nine
million dollars winner-take-all this is
Capital One's the match we promise a
unique and exclusive broadcast both
golfers are miked up there on the
putting green right now let's take a
listen as they go through their
preparation I guess that's what he need
us match play my friend you know have to
make them play no I think they're gonna
put them out there I don't be too
friendly inside thinking nothing of me
it depends on how much is worth there is
no circle of friendship there's a price
for a price tag on friendship voices you
know nine million dollars Pat Perez the
most honest person I've ever met
samuel l.jackson legend and Charles
Barkley I would say the most
entertaining person on telephone Thank
You Adam I appreciate that I'll pay you
later how excited are you guys for this
I can see you got a little juice in you
just don't look at me like that golf man
you play have a whole nother
appreciation what's getting ready to
happen and people who gamble with their
friends every day have an even greater
appreciation as what's gonna happen
I'm just excited you got the greatest
golf we ever live which is Tiger you got
arguably one of the five to ten greatest
players in field who got the best short
game ever and listen one of these you
play golf is to gamble and to take money
from your friends oh yeah well I bet
like I music I bet I bet like I mean yes
he does yeah you bet with your ego pad
not to go yeah I'm with you better what
do you think this first hole two hundred
thousand dollars it started off all the
trash talk and really start a few days
ago on Tuesday I'm willing to risk a
hundred thousand that says i birdied the
first hole so so that's how good I feel
heading into this match
you don't have to take it you don't have
to make it at all but I'm gonna so you
think you can make birdie on the first
hole I know I'm gonna make birdie on the
first all double it did you see how I
baited him like that yes yes 200 says i
birdied the first hole how does that
change anything Pat 200 on that first
hole more aggressive less aggressive
where do you stand
no I think they're both gonna played the
hole but the same than iron down there
and then I think that pin location could
be phenomenal for Phil you know he's
such an amazing player I think that he's
gonna get himself down just to the right
there about that 256 maybe just passed
that there and had a nice little wedge
in there the green funnels from right to
left so he's gonna hit a little hold
wedge in there should fall right to it
and I think is that gonna make three Sam
I you looked at my teeth 393 said he
could do that today man it's not about
course management nobody paid to see the
Bay bunt so everybody's got to hit home
runs today well you gotta follow about
the guys in trouble in front of you got
to be in play to win the hole yeah it's
that simple you guys have played with
both of these you've exchanged money how
does Phil's ability to try and get in
Tigers head and maybe get him more
aggressive play into this whole match
well first of all feels gonna be
aggressive that's just his personality
yeah I think was gonna be interesting
ister trash-talker field is more of a
natural trash-talker than Tiger like
Tigers the Tigers just a natural-born
killer he's a Kobe Bryant Michael Jordan
type guy he don't smile I mean he's kind
of guy who walk
to you and Katy won't even smile
feelings you'll feel might tell you a
joke right before you keep yeah but so
that's what's gonna be interesting me
how much Tiger interplays with field
alright so let's talk about that
interplay this is it from earlier you
decided a thought you go with red today
yeah you think looks good on you black
very slimming I need the help that's the
dynamic Phil's gonna be the aggressor
and Pat you've talked about it tiger
goes with the kill shot and it's very
quick it's very quick it's to the point
and there's really no comeback usually
he just hits you in your knees and
there's no comeback to him well I'm
curious let me take that sweat off is he
still wearing those mediums mediums back
in the day so everybody's muscular
that's cuz his shirt is too small he did
wear a tie so just cuz you wear a
smedium don't mean you muscular there's
mean you don't know how to get you
started trends because these most kids
are doing that today yes they are you
were asking earlier how this is gonna
work out I'm gonna educate you right now
that's why I'm here okay go play
competition right a call 9 million
dollars in extra holes if tied after 18
each player can initiate challenges
those side bets challenge money one goes
to players respective charities and how
that's going to work if it goes to 19
they replay 18 and then right next to
where we're sitting it's gonna be 95
yards they're gonna be chipping back to
that hole they're at 18 so for where
we're sitting right here it's going
right over there that and they're gonna
keep going that until somebody wins what
do you think so I think it'll be a lot
more interesting if they were playing
for half of half of Capital One's money
and half of their home we got to check
in
[Music]
and that make anybody uncomfortable it
was not your so there's 200,000 side bet
on that first hole and to see who goes
first we're gonna have that poker chip
flip coming up a little bit later you
got Tiger on one side you got Phil on
the other
we'll see who goes first who goes second
whether they defer and we got the main
man Shane bacon is gonna be all in that
first hole Shane what do you see what do
you think yeah I mean you guys talked
about it already two hundred thousand on
the line for Phil Mickelson to make a
birdie you know what the benefit for
Phil is he doesn't have to hit driver
he's just gonna poke a 2-iron out three
he says somewhere in the 260 to 270
range have a little flip wedge in there
Pat Perez mentioned it there might not
be a person on this planet you want
hitting a wedge more than Phil Mickelson
he's been a master at it over the years
decades even and what other interesting
thing guys there's two rules I know
about Las Vegas golf one you do not make
a tee time before noon and two the wind
always blows it is not blowing at all
today I mean there's not a breath out
here normally at this time you're gonna
get 20 to 25 miles per hour so that
means more birdies which would be
exciting and when you talk about
risk/reward holes the first one they're
really gonna face is the par-5 5th
that's where Natalie Gulbis is now hole
number four is a 581 yard par 5 it's my
favorite hole here at shadow Creek I
have lived in Las Vegas for 18 years and
it's a hole that I always look forward
to playing but it's also gonna be an
incredible hole for today's match and
the reason is it's a reachable par-5
just hitting a shot tee shot in the
fairway will leave you with two hundred
fifty yards into a very tight pin
placement but what makes this hole so
difficult is in the second shot you get
a variety of lies and also if you miss
the green left like Tiger did here on
Tuesday into his approach you're in the
water or if you hit it to the right you
have a really really tough up-and-down
so it makes it a big risk/reward hole
and it's also gonna be a very exciting
hole for the match awesome Thank You
Natalie and again this is the pre match
the match itself to purchase Capital
One's the match USA or Canada go to live
bleacher report.com or download the BR
live app on your phone or connect a
device you can also order if your TV
provider via pay-per-view for those of
you not in the US or Canada please
contact your local TV provider to buy
via pay-per-view I want to give you guys
Adam I got
question I want to leave footpath sure
had obviously feels lefty Tigers variety
does the course or any holes favor one
of those players that's a good question
you don't watch TNT I'm full of them
brother great course I don't know I I
don't know if it favors either one of
them I know Tigers played here a million
times is that multiple properties for
certain holes I don't know I I don't I
don't think there's really any I mean if
Tiger can draw that driver on number
five or four the par-5 I think can get
that thing is way down there and then he
can have an iron and Feliz gonna have to
cut it so it's gonna take a little
distance off that I think the the key
holes on this front side the first five
or three and four yes you know cuz
they're long and then they got the par-5
I think whoever can can win it some of
them win both those holes they're gonna
be in business these two guys you know
the characters it's a rivalry that's
going back decades and let's get into
what they've done the numbers themselves
you kind of know that Tiger has the lead
fourteen majors to five a hundred and
seven to forty nine the money about
thirty million dollars more as well but
it's not just about numbers it's what
they've said what they've done what
they've seen and it's a rivalry that
we've really enjoyed it's led to the
match I've always been one to enjoyed
watching rivalries I appreciate what
they bring the competitiveness and also
their entertainment value to you think
in the red sox-yankees Celtics Lakers
have passed it's the intensity that each
competitor brings to the table you need
somebody like that to push you to
greatness he and I have certainly
competed head to head quite a few times
full and I battled majors I do have a
picture of him sliding that jacket on
yeah I felt good we battled into our
events and only do people are number
for the first half of my career he owned
me that's unequivocal however the last
10 years I've gotten the better of him
disposes of woods going head-to-head
with him brings out a certain intensity
certain pressure and thanks for a great
opportunity we've been grinding you
trying to beat one of them for 20-some
odd years out here why do you go to a
golf cart that's not to make a cut is to
win
or well honey we're still intense rivals
we both desperately want to win do you
think you know who's gonna win play the
pick'm challenge go to game dot BR dot
live if you get a perfect score so
you're picking tiger or Phil or have a
million dollars and a four-night
all-expense-paid trip to Vegas little
insight here apparently all of the picks
are on Tiger for every hole except for
the par threes those are all going to
fill we have Natalie with Tiger out
there at the Audi driving range Wow
there's nine million reasons why anybody
would want to win today's match why do
you want to beat Phil because it's just
Phil you know we've we've always gone at
it and there's nothing better than then
beating him and making him squirm and
you know obviously we have a lot of
money up on you know on the line and
there's nothing better than taking you
know money from Phil with all the side
game and the the different strategies
and everything that's gonna be going on
does that change your strategy when you
have just such a unique type of format
for today absolutely does you know we
were trying to figure that last couple
days of after looking at the golf course
you know what we're gonna try and do to
make him feel a little squirmy and a
little uncomfortable and there are a few
places that we've got I think I think we
could put some some challenges on there
but also it's a Evan the flow of it you
know it's just trying to at the right
moment you know pull a little game on
one other and hopefully I can time it
just right
well I can't can't wait to watch it
we're all excited to see it what are you
gonna do to get under fill' skin just a
little bit can you give us give us one
thing that you might do well there are a
few things I will probably do and you
know one of them this is talking at the
right moment you know Phil you know
likes to hit in rhythm
he likes to visualize things like to go
into his own little mind which is
actually a crazy thing in itself kind of
a scary place but it's just timing it
just right and try and get under skin
well have fun out there today all right
a little well-timed trash talk by Tiger
you think we'll get one in the backswing
man this so beautiful out here right now
isn't it great
this is beautiful what a nice way to
spend Thanksgiving weekend this is just
awesome I'm glad to be here
that's nice we're glad to have you chuck
thank you thanks thanks for showing up
ago actually I'm here I'm not the one
not getting paid here - I must have
gotten a little bit of yours though yeah
okay yeah now look we enlisted at
Columbia professor's name's Mark Brody
he looked back at the history of Tiger
and thing every single shot they've
taken and then put that on the Shadow
Creek course then they simulated it 100
thousand times and that's how they came
out with the wind probability for the
front nine as you can see favoring Tiger
favoring Tiger favoring Tiger all and
then you get to that hole five then we
go fill here but we're gonna be updating
this as this goes on the entire time but
the bets right now the line the wind
probability all of it is favoring Tiger
and I'm someone that likes to put money
but I'll be honest
College Columbia professor came up with
the yes mark Brodie Brodie clearly had
too much time on his hands he got enough
to do now apparently these yeah hundred
thousand simulations I want to go
through the third hole with you pat
because I look at it it's a par four for
86 97% of wagers right now are going on
Tiger do you agree with that I think
that's only because of the length of it
you know it feels not shorty though you
know what the pin placement is
I don't know I think this holes gonna
have myself but there's I don't think
that a single person has wagered yet on
a half so you would be the average I
would go at the half here because this
is not an easy this is not an easy three
you know 476 to the second part of this
hole was uphill now there is a backstop
up there if you want to play left or
just behind it it will funnel back to
the hole so you can't make three all
right now the fourth hole is a par 5 564
and this is a great hole so like I said
Tiger if he can draw it around that
corner a little bit he'd get himself
down there and get him a little bit
closer to that bunker which then opens
up the hole for him with a shorter Club
like I said Phil's gonna have to fade it
so he's gonna take a little bit off and
I don't know if he I know they can both
get there in two but that shot will be a
little more difficult and I don't know
if you want to try to fade it Mike
Phil's gonna have to and bring that
water to play Tiger can kind of get it
out a little bit more right and draw it
into that that green got another
question for you Pat shoot well how long
you been on tour 18 years 18 years how
has you know a lot of people are
complaining that now they're just they
just making these golf courses so long
it taking the little guys out of the
equation
in your 18 years how has the distance on
Golf Course has changed it has but you
know if we still have we still have some
short courses no we have colonial we got
to Sony we got you know Mayakoba we had
CIMB we had you know Korea and if you
look at like Matt Kuchar one the other
day and Cameron Champa chances are
chasing him and he you know he's 60
yards by him yes and Kuchar beat him by
like five or something so you know the
length is really apparent in the last
two years opens where the course has
been 77 yards the fairways have been 40
yards wide that's where you see the
length where you come into play because
that only brings in ten players that
really can't win like it looks is farm
well he's he's one of those names this
Cameron Champy's a clear and present
danger that Cameron Catron we I'm
looking forward to seeing him in
personal I mean he's the one already
this year he's been in the top 10 two
other times I can't wait for the season
to get going see this player alright so
you're seeing right now Tiger taking
shots over at the Audi driving range let
him rip with the beautiful tracer and I
wish you could have the tracer for every
shot you do on
to her yeah that would be cool yeah that
would be cool
I'd also like to see it where the tour
would have everybody play if he paid
enough amount you know the TV's already
set up there I want to see where you can
watch all the golf all the day yeah you
know I mean the cameras already there
whatever it costs you got to pay to
watch everybody you know of course
everybody wants to watch tiger that's
not the question but you know when you
have somebody else it's on you know it's
something from your hometown you want to
watch them it'd be nice to actually
watch them you know I mean Ashley I
think there's gonna be a time well you
can specifically order your player that
would be great that's what it should do
I think at some point in the next ten
years you you don't have to pay for it
though no that's fine like if you want
to watch your son or your favorite
player play you gonna have to be able to
buy a separate package for that I
believe is creminis I think it would be
great you know what happened on that if
it's helped with every other sport you
buy all these league passes and people
pay you know I paid five hundred the
first year for the NFL package couldn't
wait to do I mean listen to em you pad I
mean it'll be like three people buying
your pack three oh yeah that hurts you
and your brother only called me once a
year to come to my new year I never call
you yeah but you come to my party yeah
but I don't ever call you your free
drink and food you always come I'm
always there for that I don't know that
I know she ain't bacon we'll be down for
that too and he is with Phil Mickelson
at that alley driving race Shane yeah
we've talked about the first of all the
two hundred thousand you joked with
tiger I go to them into that why does
the first hole set up for you why do you
feel like there's a really good chance
you can walk away with a three because
the fairway sets up perfect for just a
little cut to iron and then I'm gonna
have a wedge in and the with the pin
location being along the left side along
the water it allows me to kind of carve
a little cut wedge which is a shot I
feel very comfortable with so if if
statistically let's say I birdie thirty
five percent of the holes thirty percent
of the holes this one is significantly
higher because it just fits this the
shot pattern that I like so I feel like
the odds are in my favor but you never
know you still have to ask execute and
fill this is supposed to be your
offseason you've been out here grinded
man and we've seen on the range we've
seen you on the golf course what's the
game like right now well the games as
sharp as it's been I had a rough kind of
second half of the year after a great
start and
Andrew and I kind of got to work and and
use this month as an opportunity to get
my game sharp for the match as well as
for next season and to start playing at
the level that I know I can play it was
great to win this year and get it back
but I have expectations of winning
multiple times each year and I feel like
my game has come back so I have been out
here grinding it's also an opportunity
for me Shane to get just a little bit of
a fraction back on on the many decades
of frustration that Tiger has given me
throughout my career because of his
great play and Natalie asked Tiger how a
tiger can get under your skin how can
you get under Tiger skin that's that's
tough to do because he's so mentally
sharp and and focused I don't have a I
don't have a great answer and even if I
did get it under his skin he would never
show it he'd never let you know but I
feel like I have a few things ready for
him that a little comment here a little
comment there that hopefully won't cross
any lines but will be just enough to get
him thinking and take him away from his
focus on his own game because we all
know what he's the greatest of all time
when he when he's on there's nobody
that's ever been better Phil Mickelson
has some stuff up his sleeve I am shot
as we send it back to Adam now Charles I
know you love one thing more than
anything and that is Twitter are you
ready for tweet Trey Wingo I don't think
he's in the basement with his drawers on
but clearly I did a show yesterday
nice clearly the early winner on the
match pregame is Pat Perez his hair I
was looking for you guys a hair and
makeup this morning where were you well
we came later it took you longer listen
so that's a good thing about it Pat you
can do a show and baby you can do it
we got Rickie Fowler to Charles you want
to read it Oh first of all you're trying
to say I can't read I'm not Shaq brother
I'm not sure I can read listen Pat you
can do a shoe in Vegas after you get up
there tonight with a jacket oh hey hey
hey hey hey Gladys Knight the pips
my name are you saying
coca-cola Invitational pro-am right on
this course and he's got Brad Jordans on
to tomorrow's my favorite joints right
there I won't admit that these are
amazing looks Michael stuff is amazing
yeah I didn't say all that now I'm
saying his team is playing very well
Kimmel walk has been unbelievable this
year I got to give a shout out to the
Charlotte man they played fantastic
Kemba Walker has been lighten it lighten
it up my Sun Devils win the other night
over here t-mobile people toss state
Bobby Hurley is not really Sun believe
he's gonna do a fantastic so who you got
any the duel in the desert you'd like
you to take y'all go beat Arizona but
that's not in the question I'm not gonna
say anything about the Iron Bowl I'll
take the pressure off ya back nine Win
Probability
again Mark Brody Columbia professor went
through crank the numbers 100,000 Tigers
Tiger Tiger Phil Tiger 11 there I know
this is one of your favorite holes Pat
take me through 11
I love 11 it's a little apart a little
par for drivable is kind of a I know
what kind of shape you call it another
shape guy but it it's got a real narrow
front swings around this big bunker on
the left over there and they got the pin
on the left side today I believe it's
gonna play a three or four and the
firmness of the greens can be hard to
actually get it on the green here in one
so both of their short games are
phenomenal so I expect to expect two
threes here possible chip in for a tube
what kind of place are we talking about
today
pin placements on the left on that one
17 is over here on the left and if they
would like you know if you were to say
Friday Saturday Sunday what is it
Thursday father said probably Sunday
Sunday yeah I caught something over at
the bar the other day yes I look pretty
good up the sheet there at the bar so
some guys walking around Vegas with that
sheet all right let's let them in the
fill and
you're on the Audi driving range oh man
this is just a sound that is so big he
talk it doesn't it
almost it's like looking at a mirror for
me it is I know a lot of people who
swing look like that but ball does not
fly like that's true you know what's
amazing Sam you play with a bunch of
pros and I was the pad you're a pro it
is so much fun to play what a
professional we take it for granted how
great these guys not just these guys
like Pat's a great player you know I
played I played with Tom Lehman and
Bernhard Langer and their turn in this
tournament last week
just watching pro golfers swing man it's
just amazing they're bad shots are
really good shots Bozak's yeah but this
one in the red shirt it's the best one
I've seen swing fruit you know as you
hear $25.00 now I've seen him play for
34 years competed against them but I'm
telling it's unbelievable the most
impressive thing going it's good now as
it was back in 2007 anything man this
guy he's the greatest of all time no
disrespect to Jack Nicklaus ain't about
if the home this guy's to goat he's
Michael Jordan of golf and it's been an
honor and a privilege to watch him play
now it really has now we're gonna have
both golfers miked out the entire time
and we hear some more talking
yeah well let's get going on out there
put a little bit of chattiness this is a
nice touch have some goodies trying not
to act winded but I am I'm winded all
right you know what son you want like a
5% in client you know you know it's
amazing when I'm playing for the Phoenix
Suns fields wife Amy was a dancer so I
got to get I got to play golf a lot I
will feel there's been a lot of time
with him one of the great guys know
people know he's a great golfer he's
been a me just a just amazing people on
speed really as I listened to Tiger
not further somewhere on that
we shoot hmm that is unbelievable
damnit
73 points up curse words the last time
we saw both of you guys playing then he
planted we're getting beat down yeah
yeah Ryder Cup new at the Ryder Cup Sam
I saw you over there how was that no we
want I don't even well thought you were
listening to those guys you're not
listening that's like Oh No so how was
the Ryder Cup Sam um different kind of
setup man I mean if you were a half inch
off the fairway over there you and some
three foot rough Yahoo's just it was set
up - it was set up for us to fail or
anybody that misses fairways to fail
just that way beautiful Golf Course done
Wow so you just left
let me see the talent
thank you
so Tiger do a little bit of Trackman
work here I can't really read and what
it is 4200 spin I'm hoping that so at
4200 spin I'm hoping that's a 4-iron
that would be a great number for ya what
are we looking at with that phone so the
phone is it shows you a ton of numbers
and Tiger Dan obviously knows them all
but that bomb that the track man follows
the ball and it gives you all these
readings based on what it is so give you
club bat speed to give you path they'll
give you swing ratio to path will give
you watch angle spin launch angle peak
height all that things so you know when
you're talking about how far you want to
hit irons and clubs in general you use
this and you have to have a certain
amount of spin with a certain amount of
loft to get what you want and that's
what he's trying to dial in right here
and I think I'm assuming that the for
him because he hits his foreign about
227 it might be a 5 though he's swinging
fantastic rips when you guys are just
going oh and up well you know I've seen
this swing forever I'm a fan I have this
group in my mind I've seen this a
million times but this looks as good as
I've seen it in a long time and the best
part about this effect he's pain-free
finally yeah that's what's so awesome
about I think the last doctor they fixed
him I think he did a phenomenal job this
looks like the old days but this
actually looks better this is kind of a
mix of two in my opinion in his career
and this looks just phenomenal it is
closer to butch or Hank it's not Hank
you know it's a little bit more of it's
a little bit old yeah but he was a
little bit shorter there and he had that
faster twitch going through the faster
hips this is more of a vibrant cuz I
Brett's talking about they can watch it
in action live doublet report.com
TV provider via pay-per-view every
single TV provider has this available
but you can also download the BR live at
you were talking right there about his
swing and how good it's been that's how
you get 280 career wins we know that him
and Phil combined over a hundred and
twenty wins the guy that created this
course has created over a hundred and
twenty courses let's listen to how Tom
Fazio created the Majesty that is Shadow
Creek for the match
when I first heard about the tiger
filled match I thought wow they couldn't
have picked a better place that Shadow
Creek not because I designed it but
because Shadow Creek is a distinctive
one-of-a-kind kind of place it was a
vision to build an environment and put a
golf course in it Shadow Creek is a
perfect course for this because it's
going to create an intimate feel much
like the older tournaments from back in
the early 1900s
well shadow is a little bit on the
tighter side off the tee relative
lengthwise it's really not that long and
a lot of birds can be had for sure from
a golf designer standpoint we had all
the ability to do whatever we wanted to
do Shadow Creek is one of those golf
courses that it's the total package
there's no one great golf hole the
environment of the whole property is so
distinctive and unique it's a golf
course that you stand on the first tee
and you go WOW when you see it you look
at the mountains and the long-range
views you say how could it be any better
than this and the first par 3 happens to
be the fifth hole and the fifth tall
place over a big of this we actually dug
a hole in the ground 60 feet in the
ground and then we take the golfer down
through it to get up to the green so
that golf hole is one of those awesome
settings for golf and it's a very
distinctive golf hole now coming back to
the clubhouse the 17th hole par 3 that
is maybe the most unique on the property
because of its elevation the lake in
front of the green waterfall behind the
green it's arguably the best hole this
17th hole will be a very very memorable
hole for everyone
the 18th hall has everything that all
the other holes have combined into one
golfer
we have elevation off the tee hitting
over a big ravine lakes on the far side
right side of the fairway with
waterfalls in each one of the lakes
everything he was seeing on the property
throughout the entire Golf Course and
it's the kind of thing you say wow this
has been a special place I can't wait to
go play it again
if it's a sporting event that matters
the Goodyear blimp is odds-on favorite
to be floating on top the odds-on
favorite for superior performance
Goodyear more driven
I now want to toss it to the three best
dress men in the state of Nevada Ernie
Johnson Peter Jacobsen and Derek Lowe
got that right yeah it might be right I
know but no this makes us all
uncomfortable thank you very much Adam
just going back to what we just saw
about this golf course it is simply
spectacular I've seen videos of it I've
seen photographs of it but until I drove
this golf course yesterday there are
holes here that just mesmerize you with
with the fall colors with the waterfalls
with the lush fairways it's unbelievable
this course was created out of nothing
it was a flat Las Vegas Nevada desert
and what they did here what Fazio did
here is spectacular specimen trees from
all over the country and this is what
you get it reminds us a lot of great
golf courses we played yeah a little bit
of Pine Valley in there a little bit of
something deal a little bit of this
something they're just amazing golf
course but to think that was created I
mean you're right their plan you cannot
see one Vegas landmark there so the gone
down in and you could be it's just like
a little haven you could be anywhere so
all all of those things being said and
and rightfully so about the beauty of
this place are these guys gonna chew it
up and spit it out
I think they will I think they've moved
the t's up we're playing the golf course
shorter than we normally would see in a
professional event but that's the whole
point we want to see birdies we want to
see Eagles we want to see challenges
come on I want to see guys punch out
come on no you see that on daily basis
when you play what we want to see and I
think what everybody wants to see is the
trash-talking trying to get in each
other's heads
we want to see birdies Eagles chip-ins
and maybe all in one yeah dependence of
the can right there today there they've
made them accessible you're gonna see a
lot of them coming off the back boards
they're gonna the ball come and
naturally filter if they have to chance
there's gonna actually filter in there
and we're gonna see lots of birdies and
eagles so and that's what it should be
what are your memories darren of the
year 2000
and here you are playing tiger 36 match
play in the finals and you beat it was a
4 and 3 you beat up Greg yeah with just
I wasn't really in the finest physical
shape I think I'm gonna play 36 holes
against the best player the work right
there at that stage but I got lucky he
had a bad day I had a good day and you
know I made very few mistakes and that's
what that's what's made Tiger and
arguably the best player the game has
ever seen because he made very few
mistakes and I'm that particularly he
had a bad day and I have a good one but
Tiger play as smart as well Jake where
does where does pressure enter into the
equation today and and will either of
these guys in this kind of a setting
feel pressure today I don't think
they're gonna feel pressure on the first
five or six holes they're gonna be kind
of feeling each other out like a like
like a like a match boxing match they're
gonna hopefully get off to a good start
but I think we're gonna see it really
wrapped it up on the back nine you're
gonna see them try to get in each
other's heads on the front nine and then
try to throttle them on the back side so
I really don't know who's gonna have the
advantage going in Phil's passion is is
unbridled Tigers precision is incredible
so you're really looking at two
different styles of play Tiger who and
Phil who is he's like a maitre d at a
hotel in a restaurant he greets
everybody as we watch them hear how
important will it be I know Phil has
talked about getting off to a quick
start if he does not does he have a
chance I think he's going to struggle I
think the start is more important for
Phil than it is for Tiger and we look at
those who the majority of those holes at
the start all the trouble is on the is
on the left
Phil's miss miss is to the left whenever
he's not quite on song so I think you
might seem go with some safe Club some
irons off the tee to start off to try
and get the ball in play he doesn't want
to give Tiger Woods a start if he gives
him a head start weak and he's been
dissecting the golf course giving him
the best opportunity to attack the club
and a lot of time that's going to be
less than a driver it's going to be a
long iron or a 3-wood because we know
Phil and Tiger both are not as accurate
off the tee as they wish they would be
Phil probably more so than
but Phil's short game is incredible it
kind of reminds me of seve back in the
days but if you get if you get into a
short game wrong with Phil I think Phil
wins yeah but it's gonna take that many
shots actually get there that's that's
the question you know Tigers gonna be
there anything every time you don't know
what Phil is going throw out here there
could be one he could rip it down the
flag for three or four straight shots
and then had one 40 50 60 yards off line
you just don't know what you're gonna
get let's eavesdrop here
I got a question for both players both
of you have you ever felt great where
he's standing right now and then get on
the course and have one of those days
and or have you ever had the exact
opposite when you say man I just don't
feel like I got my A game and suddenly
bang I'm playing a tournament many many
years ago in Monte Carlo and I was on
the readings warming up definite
chunking it shot 60 well I'm pretty
messed up anyway so it's always scary to
me when I have a great warmup
because it comes to easy because you see
I feel - good what's gonna happen and
when you get a bad one on two or three
or four you think oh the roofs caving in
so I really don't put too much stock in
my warmup for that reason alone as we
send it back to Adam in the gang Chuck I
got a question for you right yes sir
because I know that you were taking aim
a bit at Tiger and his and his medium
shirt
and I and I see your decked out and
you're decked out in the brand-new shirt
today can you give me some idea of the
thighs on that tag that's triple extra
videos like I've been Diesel xxx
listen you moved a sucker place dr.
Darren's hair there inherit looks a lot
believable I got a question for you
Ernie says some and he Jake says
something as a professional golfer how
important is your warmup like do use
like if I'm hitting it good or I'm
hitting it bad how's that psyche played
it's been it's been both for me I've hit
it horrible and got on shot 65 and I've
hit it wonderful and I've shot 76 so you
know I for me I actually like to hit
that well on the range because I get
kind of overconfident where I go
I'm gonna stripe it I'm gonna hit this
paradigm I go out for this pin listen
and all of a sudden I'm three over after
nine I go what the hell just happened
you know so it there's there's good and
bad and both players look you know
everybody that plays will tell you the
same thing they've hit either good on
the range and played great somehow or
you know but the bottom line is your
short game has to be phenomenal no
matter what what you do you go to the
range every time you play yo yeah really
yeah of course it really and I hated
crappy on the range all the time so
going then I'm getting Sam you know when
you get older you ought to get loose my
I get loose by getting my car I turn my
seat heater on you want to caterpillar
hey Chris my caddy you fired caddy for I
would love you to caddy for being leaked
Oh Chris you fired men personal a little
higher than his but I'm in first of all
I don't pay him well I do pay him a
little bit
do you have to carry money like when you
hit the fans everything you got to pay
them off those fans are so drunk out
there at Tahoe they notice the ball hit
I'm on the bag I want that back hey what
hard hats
hey I just fired Chris and you can pick
at it for me in Tahoe be everything I'm
so happy honestly to be sitting next to
Samuel Jackson Charles Barkley because
the magic you guys have is very natural
and I think what you guys are about to
witness in the rough Capital One is a
great insight you guys played shadow
Creek and apparently one of you guys had
an issue just getting dressed
so here's in the rough presented by
capital in the field and my inner Tiger
I'm gonna keep you guessing all day
lefty for fear right at the tiger
I'm amphibious as appropriate consider
how many balls you hit in the water
you got some fans and a snorkel too as a
matter of fact I do
no golf kwatak about to change your name
to surfing
earth well Chuck thank you man
listen we shot those commercials about a
month ago it was so awesome it's always
a pleasure to work with Sam I tell
people he helped me so much just giving
me little stuff on little tips when
acting normally worked with Spike but
it's always honor and privilege to work
with Sam and shout out to Capital One
man they've been amazing to work with
yeah they've been amazing Sam you had a
face of capital one on the face a part
of Capital One you know a lot of faces -
Capital One which is great do actually
have that credit card yeah do that's
what's in your wallet yeah one is that
the only one that's the only one of him
no no is that the only one of that style
you know no no no they all look like
this this is a mess we're gonna sit here
and keep talking apparently have another
job oh right nice work so anything
Thanks you were one are actually
completely out alright check it out we
got a little Instagram story from Dexter
Fowler not a bad baseball swipe there
hey that's a good dude man he's a good
dude all right so we got live mics again
live mics the entire match and we are
listening now in that Audi driving range
time
time
Oh
yes
a ball go for
86 yeah athlete 290 there
you're gonna want to watch these guys
you know that the match live bleeped
report calm download the BR live app you
can also order with your TV provider via
pay-per-view you could tell Tigers
getting a little quiet right now Phil is
gonna get ready to attack very early on
candidly I'm rooting for Phil to jump
out to a lead I think it's gonna be
perfect and I'll tell you what I want to
give a shout-out to wheels-up making it
possible for so many of these stars to
get here and to be a part of one's to
match do you think it's a ride no I
didn't get that ride that was just me
and Charles Zach and a little bit of Ben
Stiller to Ben was the right Ghost be
nice called wheels down
it was merciless terrible it's called
wheels down yeah that's what it's called
that came Southwest yeah that's called
wheels down yeah you guys go wheels up
I'm wheels down brings out you land
safely that's you feel exactly been
frickin still everybody Gaylord M Focker
you know the house yeah welcome sir oh
my god I watched going deep with the
Caroline oh I like that on Came Polly
yeah I know we landed safely it was a
nice cozy flight yeah yeah I think you
understand a good story I've been seeing
promotions for your show there's a seven
part series escape at Denham aura this
scene the setting the characters the
narrative is perfect yes and I thought
what better than a pay-per-view golf
event to promote escape it's been yeah
no no it's look it's a cold upstate New
York prison and there we are in
beautiful Las Vegas but if Phil and
Tiger were escaping from prison who
would you have more faith in well I feel
Phil would maybe take more chances or
anything so - right you know I told Ben
I actually watched the first episode did
you it was really good he said he says
there's seven parts but I watched the
first episode a couple of nights ago
really good work man Thank You Charles
thanks man I just wanted to be close to
you so I could confront you about the
Knicks and because I Ben I first of all
you'd like a typical New Yorker yes I
know you always think you're better than
y'all
listen they to Bush you're not walking
through that door here I come from wall
fridge he's not walking through that
door he's there calling every game thank
goodness but you know okay it's a tough
time but you you're just always so down
on them and yeah they they don't then
they do kind of suck right now but I got
a bright future yes they have a bright
future but they suck the last 20 years
yeah what do ya'll take it personally
y'all suck because I want my son to like
you and like you I love with Steve Steve
Mills and Scott period doing they've got
a bright future once they get the big
fella back so the message of course no
was harder acting or directing I well I
like directing a lot because I think
acting is actually harder because you
have to be in the moment how do you feel
when you do those like those scenes with
Sam like when you're in it how do you
feel
you can keep screwing up and doing it
over right right so that's the
difference between exactly you have to
kind of just be in it and directing
you're kind of like looking at
everything from the outside so different
energy yeah I think I actually enjoyed
directing more because you don't have to
it's a little less it's kind of
vulnerable when you're acting it's just
a weird thing to do when you get in
front of a camera and have to just sort
of be normal could I haven't put on this
director hat really quick change the
subject for the next note does not worth
talking about what I'm a [ __ ] is
question seriously are you the type of
director and I work with directors who
are hard on the only crew and the cast
which director are youth I think I used
to be all about the actors because I
started out as an actor and then when I
as the years went by I realized the crew
you know it's such a hard job to be on a
crew and to be doing that all the time I
think you have to figure out a way to
connect with everybody in their own way
alright but you know as a director
you're the only one who sees it in your
head you want to keep going until you
get it the way you know and sometimes
they don't you know see that because
they're you know not as invested yeah
but everybody works very hard on the
crew so you know it's can I break up
this bromance now I appreciate you very
much listen you know what do you want
from me Chuck I'm Adam
leave me alone I'm a snap well I want to
see a phil mickleson man and I got a 12
I had told me to 12 layers that
blackjack table just want to see one
thing here okay clubs a little behind me
the heads staying in uh okay that's what
I want to see thank you that was better
there I think I was just moving a little
bit add alright let me hit a fatal move
on I think it's like right on they seem
to be normalization is to under that's
to over and then a few they were under
so they seem to be right on give or take
it might be hard to win they're getting
ready for the poker chip flip to decide
who's gonna go first on this first hole
as you can see on the right side of the
screen we are under ten minutes live
bleacher report.com to purchase this
match we're gonna turn it over to the
PGA show you who rules in competition
I'm glad Kent is not here cuz he'd be
won the Rolex
gentlemen welcome to the most
anticipated match can tacit myself are
going to be walking with you is walking
referees will be there to answer any
question or procedure you have kin tack
and I'll be walking with you walking
referee to answering any can't thanks
procedural rules question you have no
better we're gonna have a coin flip to
determine the Honor we have a coin that
we have Tiger Woods on one side
Phil Mickelson on the other whoever wins
the coin toss will have the option of
taking the honor or deferring to your
opponent we're not gonna ask you to
defend the gold just to keep that coin
it's pretty cool coin yeah absolutely
okay we're ready nice okay Phil I'll
lead us off okay you're leading all no
sure might just use this good luck
gentlemen
thanks mark you see how - angle that
coin Wow I like that who's in first
I like killer I like but I like throw
him first
obviously because he wants to make three
and that's it this first hole is about
filmmaking three and nothing else
there's he knows he's got to make three
I want to see him in the fairway and if
he hits it first you know he doesn't
have to worry about what Tiger did and
this neck is a if Tiger sprays me or
something he might think something
different he wants to get out there hit
in the fairway get on the green make
three and move on how much can that
change the match if Phil wins the 200
right away and takes the first massive
he wins at 200 grand that gives him
house money to play with and that's
gonna he's gonna start to try to bait
Tiger to get that one gets that
confidence oh it's gonna be phenomenal
he gets that he can try to be tired and
you know hopefully get some big action
going on this deal Chuck my dream is a
cocky Phil you got your dream that's
kinda filled got more confidence than
any person I've ever been around in your
life yes other than Michael Jordan Larry
Reggie Miller Wow Gary pain but just for
the record that 200 grands not that big
the deal I mean I was really comforted
last night then the dealer turned over
three black Jack's in a row and it was
back to black black 200 was gone so I
just had to I was a black
multi-millionaire and I left just a
millionaire last night I'm gonna get my
money back tonight Ben I'm gonna go with
you okay make it come on baby that makes
you save me a seat I got you but you
gonna go to bed like you did last
messages losing the bed like an eight
o'clock if you're not worried about $200
just leave it by my we're gonna leave
we're gonna be billionaires that strip
has gotten smaller down there Twitter my
favorite thing in the world people who
live in my parent's garage well I'll
tell you what just in Thomas's parent's
garage looks pretty nice did he win a
PGA yeah and Dustin Johnson
oh yeah Justin Thomas man you need a
bigger TV Cody who I know they paid you
more money never to go to Alabama
come on get a bigger TV brother come on
man you got to get a bigger TV for that
wall Jared Jordan's house there they
just need to save his money for that
hair transplant who gonna go ball for
Jordan or Tiger Tiger sure that's right
ma it's right on the cusp you Charles
from being gone you know let's listen to
Tiger oh my gosh
thank you yeah thank you
hippie bunker shots till you kick those
off the green Thanks
i D
doggie
all right you want those out
oh I get a picture that somewhere I
think this should be a side action
forget 200,000 you fill beat you bring
it home oh man come on
that would be amazing oh so funny you
know I can't talk about going ball it's
nothing wrong with that I mean I took it
like a man though I don't didn't hold on
for dear life I've just shaved it off at
26 years old cried for a couple days but
it you get over the vigil we need some
comment ever remember seeing you with
hair I know but I'm your era
I don't yeah well you only six at 26 at
26 I started going bald and I realized
it's over let it go brother
listen I'm suing you and Barrett Clark
take a look at the eyes here Chuck I
know these interests you fill right now
plus 135 tiger 155 it's getting less and
less beneficial to take fill I checked
it yesterday was plus 175 that means
people are pounding Phil right now 77%
of money being placed on Phil just 23%
on Tiger Wow and I'm just gonna say it I
put money on Phil - did you really
thought the odds are worth it it's not
worth it for me to take 150 with to
happen with you from our friends at MGM
- 155 I'd rather take $100 and 0 yeah
I'm a risky guy golf is just too easy
I'm not gonna bet on golf I mean I mean
- easy I mastered it Pat you this is the
first pay-per-view golf event yes taking
money on whether an MMA fight will break
out neither one these guys can fight so
stop it it's also correct the tiger I
guarantee you in between limitation I
guarantee you Tiger field had never been
on the fight in their life either one of
them no they got too much security
around them no I'm talked about even
when they were younger
I'm not chance you have no chance
no no they both great guys but they not
the toughest guys in the world he never
gonna fight in their life
I want final predictions Pat how do you
see it playing out I got the man right
there I got the cat at two and one two
and one I do I like him I think I want
to see some heavy action though I hope
there's a lot of side bets and stuff
like that that would be phenomenal Ben
your expert golf prediction I'm thinking
Phil might steal this one expert stop it
just people get paid to give there's no
such thing as an expert and I'm going to
watch
[Laughter]
right now it is the most unique sporting
event of the season the match
pay-per-view Phil Mickelson Tiger Woods
ready to rock and roll
and now to the legend himself Bernie
Johnson Wow
you